mais
voilà voilà ça y est donc on y est
diagonal l'actualité internationale du
jeu d'échecs bonsoir ce soir et loi de
relance grand maître international
nous recevons notre invité magic nicolas
kiefer voilà pour ce soir nicolas
bonsoir les amis bonsoir nicolas alors
donc tu reviennes plus sur des modèles
n'étaient pas venus donc le mois dernier
parce que deux mois voilà depuis deux
mois et encore les cheveux longs voilà
alors tu vas tu rejoues quelques
tournois la nationale et au gardien
aussi d'ailleurs
oui aubervilliers avec un tournoi qui
s'est pas trop mal déroulés notamment
lors d'une ronde j'ai pu battre mon
voisin et
j'ai joué aussi des interclubs le
week-end dernier où j'ai fait deux
points et demi sur trois donc j'étais
plutôt en forme
je crois qu'il ya une deuxième livre en
cours on avait parlé du premier tour
nous rappeler le titre sans exercice
pour progresser aux échecs
voilà qui c'était le tome 1 et le tome 2
va sortir début mars
bon on en reparlera dès que ça sortira
encore donc le deuxième pour prendre et
c'est arrivé à vers la maîtrise
il faut passer par ces étapes le premier
tome est destiné pour que les joueurs à
1600 points elo face 100%
bien entendu en s'investissant dans le
livre en réfléchissant un quart d'heure
par diagrammes et ils peuvent arriver à
100%
le deuxième tome c'est un joueur à 1800
points elo qui peut arriver à faire 100%
des profs c'est résoudre les 100
exercices
de manière correcte et en ayant vu les
idées cachez donc avec nicolas giffard
l'écrivain phare de diagonale donc en
mars on parle donc de ce deuxième tome
alors on va revenir
évidemment l'actualité de cette semaine
et loi ça bouge beaucoup moi j'ai
l'impression là on est débordé oui ça
bouge énormément donc effectivement
l'actualité ils ont le grand match qui
vient de commencer le match michael
adams contre yasser serra one donc je
connais bien michael adams
on le connaît tous bien ici puisqu'il
est numéro sept mondial on l'a revu on a
vu son interview au tournoi de jeff
koons et michael adams numéro sept
mondial contre llacer seround que
nicolas connaît sans doute mieux que moi
j'ai joué une fois contre lui
à lugano en 1989 et il avait gagné après
une longue partie et il avait été très
sympa à l'analyse
ça va durer au moins une heure l'analyse
parce que c'est une longue finale et
j'avais été impressionné par son espèce
manière de gentleman il est très urbain
vraiment un bon joueur un bon joueur et
frappé donc c'est le numéro un américain
dont j'ai donc un match angleterre etats
unis un petit peu un oui il avait déjà
fait le même match de l'an dernier c'est
ça a gagné par 5 5 5 partout c'était une
scène partout donc au match qui se
déroule aux bermudes
deuxième information de la semaine dans
toute chose aussi c'est le démarrage et
loi du kasparov grand prix online le
premier grand tournoi d'échecs sur
internet
oui grand tournoi d'échecs sur internet
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas de salle pas
de déplacements du joueur
pas de jeu d'échecs tout est virtuel
c'est à dire que les joueurs jouent
depuis chez eux sur leur ordinateur avec
un arbitre à côté pour vérifier qu'ils
se fassent pas aidé par un cerveau
électronique et il a donc il ya seize
joueurs qui n'ont pu naître short en
grèce suit de l'air à saint-pétersbourg
kasparov à moscou chacun jouant chez lui
s'est resserrée one aux bermudes chacun
sur place et donc c'est un match à
élimination directe seize joueurs
huitièmes de finale quart de finale
demi-finale finale et dès demain
garry kasparov entrera en scène
puisqu'il jouera son premier match
contre barrois le joueur indien alors je
crois qu'il ya des particularités jeu
contient un ordinateur qui joue qui est
dit junior je crois une programme
israélien dont qui joue sa chance comme
les autres joueurs et l'autre
particularité aussi c'est une première
double parce que c'est la première fois
aussi je crois que des joueurs qui sont
adam s'essaiera one qui font d'en
commettre aux bermudes joue en même
temps aux autres tournois sur internet
c'est comme se finit hors parti il se
met à jouer sur l'internet pour vous les
autres tournois sa première fois j'ai je
ne voudrais pas ce sera pas bénéfique
pour le ces deux joueurs ça m'étonnerait
qu'ils jouent bien les deux événements
et bien sûr avec internet c'est très
souple on peut jouer aux échecs 24
heures sur 24
mais d'ailleurs je pense que dans ce
tournoi sur internet il ya un espèce de
problème mais un handicap qui va arriver
pour les joueurs en décalage horaire et
ceux pour lesquels la partie se déroule
pendant qu'ils devraient dormir je pense
qu'il ya un problème qui se pose
effectivement c'est bon c'est calé sur
le
sur le méridien de greenwich meridian
européen puisque effectivement la
majorité des joueurs jouent quand même
en europe
donc pour l'instant horaires européenne
soit pour ça qu'il joue bermudes donc
ils jouent donc
du coup beaucoup plus tôt en fait en
matinée wiki jeu beaucoup plus tôt en
matinée d'ailleurs il ya certes erawan à
jouer je crois ce matin ça doit être
très très tôt bon effectivement ça pose
un petit problème mais d'un autre côté
ça faut davantage pour le public d'avoir
des partis en continu effectivement
alors derrière grande nouvelle de la
semaine après on reviendra sur le thème
de l'émission qui cette fameuse partie
kasparov les coûts avec le mois de
janvier qui s'échouent on reviendra
évidemment sur son match dan brown la
semaine prochaine quand on aura
l'ensemble des parties c'est ça y est
les lois je crois que l'on a de
nouvelles sur le grand prix de bordeaux
oui le grand prix de bordeaux donc qui
avait fait la question du concours peter
l'écho l'année dernière donc le grand
prix de bordeaux 99 été gagné par peter
l'écho rappelons que c'est qu'un atome à
deux parties rapides les joueurs
s'affrontant la cadence de 25 minutes
quatre joueurs élimination directe et
cette année le plateau sera plutôt
relevé stefan wey est plutôt relevé donc
les joueurs qui ont confirmé tous leurs
participations sont donc michael adams
dont convient d'en parler ni en 7
mondial joël lautier numéro un français
vladislav tkachiev qui a fait
l'actualité dernièrement et loi
puisqu'il a été bien produit par le club
de cannes
il a fait deux matchs superbes et le
dernier mais c'est la star locale je
crois que tu peux en parler mieux que tu
connais très bien pour elle il s'agit de
l'ancien invités de diagonale laurent
frayssinet joueurs de dax beaucoup
beaucoup de talent qui va devoir enfin
son talent va être mis à rude épreuve
puisqu'il est opposée quand même 3 3
joueurs qui font partie des 50 meilleurs
mondiaux ça va donc être très très
difficile voilà donc avec laurent
frayssinet vice championne du monde
juniors et les espoirs seront pris de
bordeaux sera en direct sur des monnaies
les 6 et 7 avril prochains
et puis pour les joueurs de la région
mais ils pourront donc aller au théâtre
fémina qui est le théâtre central de
bordeaux pour assister à ces parties en
direct partie de 25 minutes et je crois
avec nicolas giffard en commentateur
riche et très heureux que stéphane mes
invités
je vais voir ce grand prix de bordeaux
dont j'ai lu beaucoup de choses et que
j'ai suivi à distance je veux le voir en
vrai en direct live voilà avant mais on
espère que ça va être une belle édition
encore une fois cette année
voilà donc ce grand prix de bordeaux
évidemment il y aura plus d'informations
qui va circuler au cours des semaines
qui vont arriver trophée ciel ces
assurances et j'ai oublié de dire quand
même puisque la société ciel ces
assurances a décidé il doit de prendre
le nom du tournoi pour pour sa promotion
oui effectivement c'est tout à leur
honneur puisque avec la tempête qu'il ya
eu en début d'année les assurances ont
été assez une monnaie et donc cesser
renouvelle son soutien à ce grand
événement ils sont là depuis le début
donc ils associent leur image au jeu
d'échecs et donc on en est tous très
contents voilà trophées ces assurances
donc à bordeaux 6 et 7 avril voilà donc
on va revenir maintenant sur ce mois de
janvier
puisqu'on fait un petit récapitulatif
avant qu'on se casse part au grand prix
puis ce match ça donne c'est roanne et
pris leur ampleur pour qu'on puisse les
communautés de plus en plus en détail
alors moi j'ai eu envie de dire dans le
communiqué de l'émission que les deux
grandes stars pour moi deux seulement
sont peter l'écho avec sa victoire
contre kalichman et son très beau
parcours avec tant d et garry kasparov
évidemment nicolas oui peter l'écho
s'installe définitivement vers la
cinquième classe mondiale est depuis
maintenant trois ans il progresse de
façon impressionnante ses 30 points elo
par 30 points hauts à peu près si je me
trompe pas et puis et bien sûr kasparov
a été impressionnant parce qu'on
l'attend toujours
est-ce qu'il va toujours être premier
des tournois toujours dominé son monde
est toujours montré de nouvelles idées
aussi ça c'est très impressionnant quand
on voit chaque tournoi contre l'élite
mondiale bien entendu il est aidé par
doc au réal mais il a un travail
personnel monstrueuse j'ai l'impression
kasparov et il l'a montré contre vente
délit par exemple un coup c'est
stupéfiant alors kasparov a été en fait
je crois
il a maintenant 36 ans ou 37 ans on a
toujours considéré que c'était à peu
près l'âge idéal pour un joueur d'échecs
ou expérience énergie se complète au
mieux et je crois qu'il le démontre la
kasparov
il est vraiment dominateur en ce moment
mais depuis l'an dernier en fait je
crois que jouer
les reprennent possession de l'an
dernier il a gagné tous les tournois
auxquels est pas déjà participé et puis
nettement nettement
d'ailleurs on peut citer on va revenir
tout de suite c'est un commentaire à
faire là je sens mais je vous réciter
comme une information complémentaire
c'est que le 10 mars prochain
donc pendant le tournage linas à la fin
d'une tournée linares garry kasparov
accepté de nous donner une interview
chose qu'on n'a pas pu avoir avec 1,2 et
donc des moyens pour la première fois au
rallye interview du meilleur joueur du
monde le 10 mars qui sera diffusé donc
dans la semaine qui suit voilà je
finirai cette information donc tu
voulais revenir sur un point
oui je voulais revenir sur garry
kasparov a vaincu l'année dernière
puisqu'il l'année dernière effectivement
il a joué trois ou quatre tournois
il a gagné sarajevo haut la main il a
gagné pêche lundi haut la main mais il y
avait un point noir le tournage linares
où il avait fait seulement +1 gagne en
une seule partie donc terminant
troisièmes quatrièmes du temps donc
cette année on attend tous à linares
puisque c'est quand même un très très
gros tournois jeux on espère qu'il fera
mieux que l'année dernière mais c'est
pas la balle est suspendue fin on
l'espère si on essaie on espère ça
dépend si on est si on est prompt au
cospar a aussi un si on est fan
moi je suis plutôt fan l'écho pour ça je
grave ça fera un affrontement donc
rappelons quand même les joueurs de
linares puisque c'est vraiment des plus
beaux plateaux qu'on est content qu'on
ait vu dans simplement y aura kasparov
numéro 1 chronique et la nand numéros 2
et 3
peter l'écho donc numéro 6 alexander
kalichman donc champion du monde en
titre et le dernier est un mannequin et
moment qu'un c'est évidemment le 4e
mondial avec syntiron alexei shirov
voilà donc un très beau plateau pour
stone linares et garry kasparov favori
mais là il va vraiment joué que contre
des joueurs de top niveau top niveau et
avec des parties aller-retour en est à
dire une fois avec les blancs une fois
avec les noirs ce qui est plus dur
qui a tendance à plus égale égalisé les
chances puisque c'est que tu cites et
que kasparov avait souvent les blanche
contre un homme dans les tournois où
c'était une fois les couleurs et là il
va jouer deux fois les couleurs donc il
y aura les blancs contre allende et les
noirs aussi ce qu'il faut voir surtout
de la grosse particularité de ce temps
là je pense que c'est important de le
mentionner ne serait-ce qu aujourd'hui
pour puisque ça va être un des plus
beaux événements de l'année tout
simplement donc aller retour kasparov a
joué contre les ses quatre poursuivants
directs et donc ses joueurs l'attendent
au tournant c'est à dire que tous ses
joueurs quand ils sont 100 minutes se
prépare contre kasparov ne se prépare
pas en général il se prépare maintenant
contre kasparov et alors donc kasparov
ça lui fait que cinq fois plus de
travail tout simplement puisqu'il doit
se préparer contre tout le monde
alors que tout le monde se prépare comme
spécifiquement contre lui et à la
différence de ton agency là il n'y aura
aucune partie de repos s'est dit ravi ce
qu'en dit quand quatre hommes jouent
contre eux on va dire timan il est quand
même gros favoris la caisse porsche ne
sera jamais gros favori sera simplement
légèrement mieux et c'est tout donc ça
va être un tournoi très très très chaud
ce temps-là de linares qui commence dans
deux petites semaines
donc là il a une difficulté aussi
kasparov a affronté ce qui va rejouer
contre des joueurs et avec seulement
trois semaines d'écart donc il ya toute
une toile de fond psychologique
est-ce qu'il va répéter les mêmes
solutions contre le même joueur tout ça
c'est difficile
ouais mais il ya aussi le fait qui s'est
préparé longuement pour faire son match
reporté contre à nantes alors peut-être
qu'il a beaucoup de préparation en
avance sans doute ça de jouer aussi
en tout cas on verra ça tout ça
évidemment puisque on sera à linares
donc en mars pour préparer une émission
spéciale donc on va revenir donc sur ce
mois de janvier avec donc
l'excellente performance de peter les
coûts qui bat le champion du monde et ce
entre bouton ad candy et puis nos
kasparov qui survole ce tournoi hollande
et en revoyant l'interview que vous avez
donnée peter lik poko donc fin du mois
de janvier
geste newswires auprès sumud peter lee
coelho can you come and release
beginning of the tournament in so close
to you just been de kasparov en
communiquer tous les documents
communiqués think so what so we need to
talk of you voilà donc peter leko nikola
qui me disent una aux start up to be
ambitieuse il est ambitieux le petit oui
il dit pas la vérité ça fait mon avis
plus longtemps qu'il est ambitieux je
l'avais vu au championnat de paris
88 des choses comme ça cassait et déjà
tout gamin s'était envoyé à ses yeux son
regard d'auteur qu'il était très
ambitieux à l'époque avec sa mère qu'ils
n'ont et je crois qu'il est depuis
toujours il a été troisième essai de
maintenant seulement la différence bien
sûr c'est qu'il sent ses possibilités il
voit que contre les tout meilleurs et il
fait jeu égal toi et moi qui n'ont pas
cette interview moi je pense
qu'effectivement il a raison d'être
ambitieux il a les moyens et s'est donné
les moyens pour arriver dans l'est parmi
les tout meilleurs mondiaux
maintenant on peut dire qu'il se bat
pour la deuxième place mondiale
puisqu'il est à peu près équivalent à un
an du crâne qui à mon avis est
d'ailleurs le temps des risques andy a
bien confirmé sa paix qui terminent tous
dans un sac 2e ex-aequo donc l'écho
allende et krainik tout le monde
ex-aequo et maintenant le qui va qui va
arriver à détrôner kasparov autant mais
ces trois joueurs
ex-aequo mais c'est peter l'écho est
bien est favori puisqu'il est très jeune
que les voilà c'est ça effectivement
plus jeune 20 ans il me rappelle un
certain fisher ben oui par rapport à un
rosé vici à peu près le même âge quoi
morose et mitch expliquer aussi les tout
meilleurs mondiaux il ya une différence
et le style va-t-il de l'écho il ya une
espèce de solidité
on sait que pour être champion du monde
il faut perdre très peu de parties dans
une carrière peut-être de moi pour papa
de match déjà voilà si on ne part pas de
partir et quand il a le profil justement
du joueur de match du joueur qui ne perd
quasiment jamais ouais donc bon on fait
on va on verra mais bon c'est moi je le
donne mon avis je il y a des soucis à se
faire en août attend ils voient tous
croient plutôt à qui dois tu sais pas en
fait tu m'as dit que tu voyais pas qu'il
pourrait dire oui je pense vraiment que
le premier n'est pas d'actualité
garry kasparov profond là on a vu avait
choisi ces partis étaient à mon avis pas
très bonne qualité moyenne le temps doux
avec un point et demi d'avancé il fait 9
et demi sur 13
donc le l'homme pas en forme gain facile
ça veut dire qu'il a de beaux jours
devant lui encore mais bon le temps
passe on verra donc voilà on va venir
maintenant évidemment à dijon la star la
star incontestée du jeu d'échec c'est
évidemment garry kasparov alors pas
d'interview mais un petit sujet qu'on va
commenter donc en même temps que vous
allez voir ces images il s'agit donc le
sujet est évidemment sur garry kasparov
voilà je crois qu'il ya 1 minute 30
d'image que si on peut envoyer voilà
donc on voit nicolas ici garry kasparov
en train de jouer contre contrat danse
de couper le son voilà si on peut
revenir sur la voie avant le plateau
donc il doit on peut commenter ces
images allaient beaucoup d'énergie de
caspar enfin on l'a déjà dit me disent
on va voir un peu son cérémonial de
début de partie
voilà il enlève sa montre il fait ça
avant chaque partie là donc ça va être
coupée mais normalement il ajuste son
hôte cravate après justement voilà ce
qu'il fait ici c est remettre les pièces
en place il ya tout un tas de trucs
comme ça qu'il fait régulièrement et là
on le voit un peu dans la position du
fauve prêt à bondir
donc sans qu'il ait débat il est
il est bien assise et il joue ses coûts
et il avance sur l'échiquier la cassure
il est au dessus c'est pas il ya des
joueurs qui sont plutôt détaché hui non
il a dominé le terrain de bataille
alors on voit dans une autre dans une
autre partie je pense que c'est la
partie de contrôle qui m'anime savoir
voilà elle a aussi le voit marcher le
long de la salle nicolas c'est son truc
ça il peut pas rester en place et il
arpente le seul il fait il fait le tour
très très vite
on a l'impression qu'ils engagent en
fait c'est il a trop d'énergie faut
qu'il arrive à l'assortir d'une façon ou
d'une autre et ça c'est assez intriguant
aussi quand il va regarder une autre
partie on a l'impression qu'il est
méchant et qu'il veut gagner la partie
mais pourtant il joue pas on a comme
l'impression fils ok voilà c'est la
partie contre contre ian thilleman donc
maintenant c'est de mettre une autre
donc encore on le voit il ya un
contraste avec un hand qui ne lui une
manif est quasiment rien quand il joue
et une bouche comme aime le visage et on
sait le regard si l'on vient juste de
voir alors là c'est l'analyse est là
c'est l'analyse de la partie de timan
qu'on a qu'on a filmé dans la salle
d'analysé lorsqu'il était ce qui est
incroyable c'est que steam ne pouvait
pas en classe et lune
alors ça c'est à dire qu'ils commentent
les coûts et les questions et réponses
oui effectivement c'était vraiment la
leçon de kasparov et voilà voilà donc ce
petit suggestions kasparov et tout ça
pour arriver donc à partie du jour entre
15 par an fait l'écho donc les deux des
deux jours qu'on fait l'actualité de ce
mois de janvier dernier
donc une très jolie partie vous allez
pouvoir suivre avec nous mais évidemment
sur la vidéo ou aussi
deux autres façons à votre droite en
cliquant sur le bouton jouer vous allez
entrer sur un applet java qui vous
permet de suivre la partie aussi dans
son intégralité ou télécharger un
logiciel dans la partie différée de
diagonale bien que vous installez sur
votre ordinateur et vous cliquez
après donc sur le fichier pgn de la
partie le bouton pg en dessous du bouton
jouer pour voir le donc la partie dans
son intégralité de la même façon donc on
va démarrer avec cette partie voilà donc
kasparov avec les blancs contre peter
l'écho avec les nord donc premier coup
de la partie kasparov a joué 1 4 et
c'était une demi surprise c'était même
pas une surprise puisque contre peter
légaux kasparov non plus que son coup
depuis des années avec en principe plus
des bons résultats donc évidemment il
n'est pas besoin de rappeler que
kasparov rejouer le cadre des cas ces
quatre ou câblées f3 il peut jouer tous
les premiers coups existants il les
connaît tous très très bien bien entendu
ici choisi e 4 pitard les coûts de jouer
une défense sicilienne le pion ces cinq
cavaliers trois cavaliers c6 se ferment
les possibilités de la neige dehors en
sortant ce cavalier ici des quatre pions
prend des quatre qui avaient dépend des
cas d'un coup quatrième coup quand les
premiers cas c'est une position connue
et là il ya plusieurs possibilités
qu'ils soient fond noir
oui notamment une en fait ici il ya
quasiment une seule solution que dirait
on
on peut toujours tout transposé la ccil
nc une c'est une variante de ruz le dire
il ya beaucoup de petites ruses mais la
formation des noirs en principe la plus
fréquente
c'est d'aller mettre les pions sans trop
sur ces deux cases la d 6 et 2 6 le
cavalier vite en f6 et faut former a
déjà commencé par cette formation là
ensuite j'aurai fois ça a été petit rock
mais en général c'est ça c'est ça qu'on
fait au début donc ici on peut jouer le
6 on peut jouer des 6-11 le cabinet sis
que le coup choisi par peter les coûts
donc atteindre 0 4 mois c'est donc le
cas mentionné le qualifions 4 qui n'est
pas défendu
donc là un coup de dé veloppement
ensuite de kasparov au cinquième coût
écologique en sort une pièce et en
défendant la menace voyez ici pitt a
récolté un coup anti positionnelle et
joue le coup aux 7,5 c'est la défense
fait chlykov je sais pas si on peut
vraiment dire défense d'ailleurs
puisque c'est quand même très très
dynamique fondamentale semaines plus tôt
une attaque phishing off
alors oui donc ici problème problème
très nette de l'avancée de ses pions
c'est que la case des cinq maintenant ne
pourra plus être défendu par un pion
comme on sait que l'on revienne pas en
arrière il ya plus de pions c'est qu'il
est confiant sur cette colonne la ligue
et plus de l'option que 5 ne reviendra
plus niro 6 me en hausse est donc la
case des cinq est vraiment sous feu
d'autant plus que c'est sur une colonne
ouverte côté blanc c'est à dire que l'on
voit que la colonne d ici est ouverte
donc grosse faiblesse stratégique c'est
cette carte des cinq maintenant
avantages évidents c'est qu'on va gagner
du temps puisque par notre dernier coup
là je laisse vous faire des flèches
rouges et là on a fait une menace le
pion aux cinq attaques lequel des quatre
donc les blancs doivent bouger ce
cavalier et bien entendu possibilité
pour les blancs
ce serait prendre en c6 mais là après la
reprise du tube et s'implante à jackass
desa protégerait la casse clé des cinq
donc ici le cavalier blanc va devoir
partir au choix donc je dirais beaucoup
de possibilités elles sont toutes elles
sont toutes tendu et celle qui est
considérée comme la médaille d'or c'est
le sixième coup cavaliers db5 avec une
idée assez simple en fait
instaurant une petite menace de
en fait ils s'attaquent les cas seuls tu
parlais occasion faible à cause des cinq
mais aussi 7 kazan des six blindés
blancs menace probablement de bloquer
les noirs en faisant un échec du
cavalier parce que j'ai aussi une aura
changé en prenant avec le fou
effectivement ça perd en perdre à la
fois la paire de fou ce que la fameuse
paire de fou et
et aussi donc on aurait un blocage
certains des blancs sur le but adverse
oui il faut pas donner la paire de faux
dans cette position donc très
logiquement on joue des six donc là on
est vraiment dans la base sicilienne
siège lykov décide tout ça c'est la
suite bien théorique bien connue de tous
et la hausse était un coup très logique
les blancs commencent à se battre pour
cette case des cinq en éliminant un
premier défenseur
c'est qu'avec six ici contrôler la casse
des 5 mais là c'est programmé le fou g5
genre à prendre ce cavalier dès qu'il le
pourra c'est à dire dans les prochains
coups à venir justement dans l'optique
de talent et envahir la casse des cinq
avec un cavalier il ya pas de 5 à venir
des 5 sera vraiment merveilleux ce mot
clé c'est donc là peter l'écho joue le
coup de tonnerre à 6 et pour ça il faut
pas laisser ce cavalier dans cette
position parce qu'il est quand même trop
agressif on peut pas se permettre de le
laisser comme effectua une menace
directe sur sous les blancs menaçait
directement de jouer cavalier en d5 avec
une fourche est inévitable ensuite ces
sept exactement
voilà tout à fait à l'écriture pour cela
il faut qu'il dise donc à regarder cinq
essais cette voie là il y aura un échec
ensuite le cavalier ou l'autre le calais
b ou locales et des forêts pour ça qu
absolument tout de suite avant ce coup
vous chasser un câble et je laissais
lecavalier avant c'est donc à systra
logique
le cavalier repart sur de la soul qui
est disponible en a trois et maintenant
on continue dans le dynamisme on joue le
coup b5
alors pourquoi en échange de cette
faiblesse les noirs persécute en fait ce
fameux cavaliers will et on voit que on
peut retransmettre un peu le enfin
retranscrire le parcours du cavalier il
est parti de gm il est venu en relève 3
ensuite il est venu en d 4 ans 80 des 5
pour finalement arriver sur une case en
dehors de l'échiquier qui avait une case
sur le côté un cavalier
cavalli sur le côté et une mauvais
cavaliers cinq ans mais les baladeurs
qui m'a dit baladeur est ici les noirs
crée une menace grave menace menace
rouge avancé le pion en b 4 qui
attaqueraient donc les deux cavaliers
simultanément il faut quatre afin une
fourchette une fourchette esthétique
esthétique
la rb5 c'est un coup effectivement alors
on va revenir j'en très vite sur le
huitième coup dans cette position là
avant que les noirs jobé 5
les blancs vous les replacer ces
cavaliers à trois avec un parcours très
assez simple en c4 en e3 et en d5
c'est vraiment l'enjeu de cette position
assez de la case des 5
si les bleus arrivent à se regrouper
autour les noirs vont devoir défendre
toute la partie si les noirs arrivent
eux mêmes à jouer des sites et 5 ça ira
donc là la menace blanche positionnelle
jdir était ce fameux planqueel ce tracé
de cavaliers envers ses 4 3 des 5 qui
aurait permis d'assurer le contrôle de
celle des 5 à une double intérêt c'est
d'empêcher ce qu'amélie c4 puisque le
pion beceem gct contrôle notamment la
case et des stores et cette fameuse
menace qui bouge et blanc à réagir oui
mais ça obligeait dollar agir donc fou
prend m6 ont fait d'une pierre deux
coups c'est à dire que on va évacuer le
cavalier c3 avec un temps de gain de
temps mais on va l'évacuer on le met en
dessin alors peut-être peut-être on va
revenir donc qu'aucun numéro 9 des noirs
les noirs choisissez dans cette position
de prendre et le pion alors on a dit
souvent qu'il fallait éviter de les lois
de
d'affaiblir son rock par exemple donc là
les noirs on va avoir du mal à roque et
on a une pression puisque si rock du
petit côté ils ont l'impression que le
roi qu'on va être un peu à l'air et si
rob du grand de côté aussi puisque les
pions sont très avancées oui alors donc
c'est une question double en fait
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait des petits
ont doublé et ensuite où on warocqué
alors première question c'est sur les
plans doublé très simplement
la remarque est simple on vient de
reprendre avec le pion géant f6 on a
donc deux pions doublé mais en fait ça
va être juste un mois deux fois plus
efficace parce que là les blancs sont en
train de resserrer les cases blanches
alors il va falloir exploser ces cases
là et notamment ce turbo 4 donc là au
programme maintenant f6 f5
on met le pion là on échange les options
d'une façon ou d'une autre
et après on a le deuxième pion qui vient
en effet 5 et là on commence vraiment à
prendre tout le centre donc là exemple
un contre-exemple d'octobre doublé
efficace dynamiquement
oui c'est à dire ça va être un double ça
va être deux fois plus efficace que s'il
n'y avait qu'un seul jeu pour faire une
remarque générale dans cette ouverture
les noirs font découvrez ment pas
esthétique vraiment se crée
volontairement un trou dans leur camp ou
un cavalier blanc peut s'installer la
casse des 5
il laisse le roi au centre ils font
plein de coups qui sont contraires aux
lois
on a quelques débutants pourquoi pas ce
qu'ils vont trouver un espèce de
dynamisme des pièces et des pions doublé
comme des lois à l'instant qui va faire
qui va ouvrir le jeu et à ce moment là
toutes ces idées un peu statique de
cases faibles vont disparaître au profit
du jeu des pièces donc c'est normal
noirs ne sont pas en infériorité c'est
la vigne est un atout majeur de
répétition de mars et la paire de fou
voilà sinon centre vient exposer ses les
fous qui parleront un fou de cases
noires qui n'a pas son équivalent temps
plein actuellement il a l'air très
mauvais puisqu'il est bloqué mais après
la poussée des pions l'ouverture du jeu
il va jouer il a joué donc je vais
revenir dans la deuxième question
stéphane petit ou les noirs vont-ils
rockets et là la réponse est très simple
on va pas aller du grand côté puisque là
il ya carrément plus de temps devant moi
on va jouer petit rock puisque ce fou
angers 7 sera devant le roi déjà le faut
et fritons de métrange 17 devant croit
le roi pour aller sur la case à chocs 8
et comme les blancs n'ont plus de fous
de cases noires ils ont beaucoup de mal
à asséner un échec au roi noir circulent
sur la colonne ça sera bouché par
l'option h7
oui la colonne âge sera bien protégée et
sur la diagonale les blancs n'ont plus
de pièces pour faire chaque soir à l'ats
par la dame mais des noirs - foot
défense donc ici au programme fou j'ai
cette petit rock puis f5 non-échange les
pions et relève 5
on prend le centre alors une fois voilà
qu on a gagné c'était l'on va mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe ensuite
alors ici donc très logique garry
kasparov prend la case des cinq puisque
il enlève la menace b4 un type qui
planait quant même b5 b4 le pion pouvait
gagner les deux cavaliers comme tu l'as
si tu es tout à l'heure et il mais en
fait c'est ce carré sur la bonne case
qui l'a d'audit pour laquelle il s'est
battu puisqu'il a donné un fou contre un
cavalier pour avoir cette classe oui oui
avec oui mais non jeu jallet rajouter
quelque chose de faux il ya une autre
non pardon mais moi aussi alors qu'on
était nouveau allons-y donc au 10e coup
mais non ça y est voilà combien
d'expliquer le premier bédié f5
parce que si ce pion aux quatre disparus
du coup la casse des signes n'est plus
aussi faible depuis en quatre soirs par
là pour bien défendre donc c'est l'idée
de ce coup disons que la deuxième idée
c'est quand même une fois qu'on aura
changé ses pions on va jouer f5 puis au
4 et ouvrir la diagonale du fou à angers
7 à dire imaginons que ce qu'un euro 5
avance ici le [ __ ] orange et 7 un
poste merveilleux puisqu'ils contrôlera
toute la grande diagonale ça ça fait
partie des idées noires maintenant les
blancs sont pas dépourvus d'idées c'est
ce qu'on va voir tout de suite ces trois
ans que nous le calme avant la tempête
alors ces mails voulait intervenir il ya
une autre façon de jouer avec les blancs
qui comme ça à priori à l'air plus
ambitieuse c'est de jouer le fou en d3
protéger le pied au cap puis la dame à
droite en h st il va être serré elle est
très très activement place et donc le
fou en d3 et la dame en h5n1 kasparov en
fait ils choisi la voie la plus
tranquille dans cette variante je crois
oui oui c'était 3 je sais que karpov
d'ailleurs employé ces trois mois c'est
celle qui me paraît plus logique fou des
trois dames h5 je ne sais pas
effectivement je suis pas très bien
renseignés sur les forces fraîches nikov
belge pour moi on a vu ça l'autre jour
j'en parlais je crois
l'idée de jouer les points noirs le
conte carrier hausse est donné oui alors
tu fais bien le mentionner puisque
justement ici c'est une sorte de match
aller on va pas citer trop de variantes
partir effectivement c'est les deux
doivent partir pour les 9 à partir trop
long moi je pense que kasparov joue
d'une manière très logique
il veut replacer sa pièce mal placé le
cavalier à 3 alors ça c'est un double
intérêt secousses et 3 sarah empêche
aussi au lait noir de mettre leurs
cavaliers sur la case des 4 way qui
aurait pu être un coup tu peux être
envisageable donc ça reste qu'à ceux des
quatre ça protège des classes noir donc
et ça permet effectivement de recycler
le cabinet vraiment revenir à la façon
de jouer les parents ont des blocs ou
précédent kasparov avait déjà battu cram
nique et lautier de cette façon là mais
on se demande pourquoi les blancs laisse
le pion aux 4,4 et perdu oui alors
effectivement ça
ça m'est même pas venu à l'esprit de le
prendre ce pion alors je ne sais pas
c'est peut être l'habitude de jouer la
défense shicoff ce qui fait qu'on oublie
simplement que le bio est en prise quand
on est côté blanc alors pourquoi
la question m'a l'air assez sérieuse
donc ça a étudié mon c est en fait c'est
effectivement une variante possible
il est noir pour reprendre 1,4 donc
voilà je sais pas ce que tu en penses
mais je crois que c'est chaud les blancs
nous sommes prêts pattes ce pion et
continuerait la main d'oeuvre du
cavalier priori et misant sur le renoir
qui est ok il manquerait un temps pour
faire l'autre qui retombe à part analysé
cette possibilité mais en tout cas
analysés faut faire attention il ya des
subtilités dans les coûts des grands
joueurs mais cette aide à maintenant le
problème semble donc l'option ne sera
plus aux prises depuis longtemps font
preuve 5 et leur fils de logique alors
davantage de ce coup pour l'énorme bruit
blanc de le jouer plutôt que de laisser
les noirs afin de protéger le pion est
de permettre aux enfants de jouer après
5 c'est que fulham 5 empêche le pion 9,7
de bouger effectivement c'est pas
vraiment y perdre de temps puisque
maintenant le fou noir bloque un peu et
ça va obliger les noirs justement se
replacer donc continuons qu'avait laissé
deux maintenant on est vraiment dans la
logique du plan
on s'en fout s'il faut remplacer ce
cavalier qui était toujours mal placé à
la bande qu'on n'est jamais bien placé
ce cabinet est ici là kasparov
quel sport plein coup agressif c'est là
qu'il va mettre en avant le défaut de
payer au noir puisque maintenant il peut
plus se battre pour le centre la
bataille a été perdue il ya plus de
pions 4,1 à venir l'avancé de ce point f
puis d'avancer deux options là
éventuellement des invasions cavaliers
ont 25
bref les noirs ont vraiment des choses à
faire si on donne trois points noirs ils
vont avoir une pression extrêmement
prometteuse donc kasparov prend en
parler devant prend les devants passe à
la contre attaque voire même à l'attack
tout simplement ils jouent à 4 millions
à 2,7 cette pétition de voir donc là on
voit qu'il ya trois pièces en action que
très important que le fouet fin qui
table sur ses idées sur ce duo de pions
mais c'est une solution qui avance et
donc faibles on le redit encore une fois
et avancer ses pions sacré des cibles on
prend de l'espace n'est on s'affaiblit
c'est à dire que avancé des pions sans
les pièces c'est pas bon avancer les
pierres sont les pions c'est pas bon non
plus d'ateliers un débat de fond là
dessus à voir et la tour très importante
dans cette position aussi puisqu'elle va
aller sur la colonne a donc c'est une
attaque qui est totalement fondée
d'autant plus que le cavalier en d5 peut
toujours venir participer
donc sur ce en fait sur ce plan là sur
ce côté là de l'échiquier c'est les
blancs qui ont l'avantagé puisqu'ils ont
trois pièces dans l'action contre les
noirs qui savent pas trop donc à quatre
un bon coup positionnelle évidemment si
les noirs présents à 4 11e tour pour un
quatre et on attaque le pion à 6 donc
ici
réponse logique de peter l'écho petit
rock sacrifices voilà sacrifice de pions
donc l'option b 5 et apprendre il aurait
pu peut-être la tour embellie oui on
connaît comme invités étaient plus
normal mais alors là je crois qu'on en
très justement 14 octobre élite dans une
célèbre party
de kasparov justement contre shirov mais
alors c'est vérifié ou peut-être une
partie de karpov vraiment tous les
grands joueurs se sont frottés cette
ouverture
je crois qu'il ya kabylie qui vient b4
posant de gros problèmes voilà on va pas
petit rock surprend v5 tu reprends b5 et
ici alors voilà on arrive sur un sur
quelque chose d'assez intéressant tout
reprend 1,8 dame prend 1,8 et maintenant
il ya tout un enjeu pour savoir quand
les noirs vont jouer ce coup f5
alors est-ce que les bleu et blanc
peuvent prendre le pion b5 parce que là
on a l'impression que le fou sur la f1
peut prendre depuis hong kong et 5 c'est
une grosse partie c'est le dynamisme
c'est alors que tous n'y a pas une coupe
possibilité pour gagner des matériels
mais tout à l'heure c'est les noirs qui
ont refusé de prendre dans le top 4 et
les orks et les blancs qui refuse de
prendre le pion b5 à cesser le dynamisme
contre le matériel dans ce parti oui
disons que personne n'ait matériel en
fait vous prendrez sens que je pense
qu'un mauvais c'est non il y avait celle
dont il ya des couacs en local et des
quatre enfants qui sont possibles
peut-être qu'à s'épanouir à des chèques
non c'est pas possible
et moi je ne pensais pas qu'il y ait
quoi que je pense simplement que c'est
vraiment une perte de temps de jeu le
fou prend b5 dans cette pétition ça
ouvre la colonne des attendait 8
peut-être tout simplement il ya un faux
procès s'il peut pas il ya dames la dame
peut reprendre
fourchette non maman ça tu dit celle qui
dit s étaient étudiés effectivement
c'est chaud je pense que vous prendrez 5
n'est pas un bon coup bon le fait est
que ça n'a pas été jouer donc cesser
kasparov monospace présents ici a été
joué cavalier celle de troyes je pense
que l'enjeu de la position c'est
vraiment secoué cette f5 et alors
actuellement ce coût n'est pas jouable
puisque suivra une pointe qu'à valider
cinq ans et cette attaque la dame
attaque la dame attaque la fois aux 6 et
le fossé perdu un oeil à un homme s'est
vite et assez vite mais il y aurait d'un
problème des six avec rentrée de caisse
blanche
oui donc ici f5 n'est pas possible des
cinq n'est pas d'actualité pire les
cours donc trouver quelque chose pour
jouer au f5 ou en tout cas pour le
menacer
je vous demande 17,4 double intérêt
voilà ou 17e coup donc les normes d'un
des sept double intérêt pour la loi
protège finalement ce pion dont vous
vous demandez ce qui allait se passer et
empêche le cook avait laissé sept avec
fourchette sur la dame et le fou est
donc menace f 7 900 menace est elle
semble totalement d'actualité maintenant
dans cette position et la kasparov se
promener d'une manière radicale il joue
18e ou g4 alors maintenant f5 n'est plus
bon puisqu'il suit vrai j'ai pris 9 5
on peut envisager rapidement j'ai point
f 5 attaquants deux fois au cices le fou
vient de reprendre
mais là simplement cavale épreuve 5 et
là on aurait vraiment les footballeurs
opposé avec fougue et s'est enfermé et
mauve et autres fous blanc détroit qui
se baladent partout sur l'échiquier et
ce serait une catégorie dans la classe
des singles comme plus toujours la casse
et 5 est donc ici peter des cours
revient au deuxième enjeu de la partie
qui n'est plus son coût 25 mai ce
cavalier en d5 et il joue cavalier ou
7,27 il essayait de voilà c'est de
supprimer cette fameuse pression sur la
case des cinq puisque ça lui il
al'avantage au centre pieter les coupes
s'il a des deux pions saint-trond contre
c'est vers les pions des 6 7 5 mais
cette caisse des cinq les vice champions
ils peuvent pas bouger
oui oui tout à fait ça
oui ils les pions bloqués quand ils sont
pas des pions se retrouve son très fort
quand ils sont en duo l'un à côté de
l'autre comme ça dès qu'ils sont comme
ça et qui semble ok c'est à dire des
faiblesses tout simplement
donc il faut absolument essayer de
déverrouiller ce cette caste des 500
salles c'est ça le but de peter crouch
donc si si logique disons que ce sont
mes faiblesses à court terme allons à
très long terme les pions sans trouble
bloqués sont souvent une force en finale
par exemple de tours d'aidé qui
commencent à avancer c'est à dire que la
tour fait un très mauvais bloqueurs
quand il ya plus de qualité sur
l'échiquier les pièces deviennent plus
fort en déjà ça c'est vrai que mon
élection sans trop c'est quand même des
pions qui sont ensemble et je sais qu'il
ya pas de doute là dessus et pas de
bleus ils peuvent toujours se renier et
d'équidés qu'ils avancent ça devient
très très dangereux extrêmement j'adore
cette partie le trouve je trouve
passionnant parce qu'un point que
nicolas est toujours les partis issus de
cette ouverture elles sont vraiment
violente car il faut remarquer aussi
quelque chose à propos de questions je
trouve moins que plus on vieillit plus
il joue violemment je pense que vous
avez très c'est possible cette
constatation
mais son répertoire d'ouvertures et de
plus en plus violents et vous les varois
il n'a jamais vraiment refuser la
violence mais quand même ils jouent
systématiquement le pion du roi alors
qu'avant c'était plutôt le pion de
madame qui est quand même plus calme et
puis donc ils acceptent les grandes
variantes les plus violentes comme celle
ci oui effectivement moi je pense qu'il
joue plus tactique qu'avant puisque
c'est comme ça de grande qualité
avant il se permettait de jouer des
choses positionnelle maintenant pour
gagner partie de l' objet d' aller
chercher des gens sur des calculs très
très long alors qu'avant c'était sa
grande force de compréhension qui gagne
et je sais pas là je kasparov reste un
mystère pour moi de toute façon bien
mais dans tellement fort sur le cumul
ans il peut jouer en fait ce qu'il veut
dans ce tournoi et puis il faut aussi
contrôler forte dans l'autre thomas
récemment contre polgar je sais pas
c'est de réaliser deux parties
quand il a besoin il va au combat de rue
il va y joue comme un voyou il fait des
attaques quelquefois on peut douter
incorrect mais pour poser les problèmes
et finalement s'en sortir comme ça il
est contredite par ailleurs je vous
invite à regarder cette partie c'est un
peu curieux de regarder ça c'est du vol
c'est sûrement et simplement du vol
kasparov était complètement perdant à
jouer une ouverture complètement
douteuses mauvaises intentions - pour
rien et a fini par
part en fumée en a qui est je sais pas
comment on pourrait dire et je dis
police a été compliqué ça c'est clair
une position qu'il a cherché parce que
c'est une position il y avait beaucoup
de calculs bon bien sûr il n'a pas dit
oui oui la nature ont pour pour rigoler
non plus mais c'était n'étaient pas
fondées et dans le même tournoi contre
adams il un pion en moins et alors il
trouve des choses extraordinaires pour
empêcher à même de valoriser le plus
c'est même avec les noirs et il joue ça
vous voyez la police selon laquelle je
fais lui tout à fait haut en couleurs
avec la dame qui est très actif non
kasparov et quand même sétif alors non
on voit la partie quand même puisque
c'est le sujet du jour 19e coup j'ai
deux foulées 2 avec menace évidemment
lequel et d5 menace d'aller en effet six
échecs et chez cobra qui se sacrifiait
réussite puisqu'elle foule s est qu'il
prend mais il aura ouvert la diagonale
du fou j'ai deux pour aller manger
la dame donc c'est un échec à la
découverte échec à la découverte ne
fallait pas non c'est pas découvert une
prise à la découverte découverte voilà
une prise à la découverte reprises à la
découverte au crible km et prend des 5
fu prend des cinq là il ya des échanges
mais voilà justement il faut pas je me
fou prend des cinq a une fois de plus
puisqu'on a redit dans un blocage total
on préfère que ce soit un fou un des
cinq d'un cavalier est ici maintenant si
si kasparov échange les fous ce qui
semblerait logique qui prendra une
option sur n'en prendrais bien entendu
du pion pour contrôler un peu les cases
blanches ouvrir la colonne f et puis on
pourrait jouer dès 6 des simples avec
une très grosse majorité centrale trop
forte à celui de 304 la salle il ya un
phénomène aussi dans cette position
c'est le roi blanc le roi blanc n'a pas
rougi qui est
oui aux mauvaises poserait pas avoir
être effectivement parler du roi noir
tout à l'heure mais finalement avec le
coup j'ai quatre essais de vis et le
centre noir kasparov se posent les mêmes
problèmes pour 100 moi oui leroy 2k
sports
maintenant il est dans un état assez
critique puisque sur petit rock on peut
pas en dire autant pour le roi noir
c'est que les cases noires autour du roi
sont faibles maintenant le toujours une
partie angers 4 donc imaginons
simplement que le fou j'essaie de ne se
poster sur laquelle f4 la dame noire sur
la caisse h4 est très vite cédé monastir
surmontable donc si tu y as part of a du
mal à faire petit arrivé alors que n'en
parlons pas c'est carrément plus légal
puisque après tout hein donc le roi
kasparov est condamné à rester au centre
est donc ici 21e coup hk il décide
d'utiliser au mieux sa tour on h1 c'est
à dire comme ça tous qu'il voue pas sa
tour qui est un peu hors jeu il va
laisser de l'activé donc ce coût est un
coup d' attaque il faut pas s'y tromper
les diasporas veut pousser son duo thion
vers le roi de peter l'écho et donc avec
la tour derrière qui quitte donc le
rentrer en jeu du coup la tour qui
soutient bien entendu et pita rico
jouent tous ans évite donc à la peter
les corvées le coutour s'est vite actifs
sa tour et a toujours son idée de faire
pression sur cette case des 5
oui c'est ce qu'on verra tout de suite
après la pointe de ce coup tours s'est
vite quelle période continue avec g5y on
convint deuxième coup un faut rappeler
un peu les coûts et loi pour pour qu on
puisse suivre tout le monde en même
temps donc 22e coup et ça y est qu'est
ce que j'essaie alors quel intérêt de ce
coup j'ai simplement parce que là il va
falloir jouer peut-être il veut jouer à
5 kg 6 mais pour l'instant la dame noire
protège bien long à mon avis j'ai
s'inquiètant compositionnel il veut
empêcher les sorti définitivement de ce
foot j'ai cet email étions comme ça ils
sont les pions sont bien placés
évidemment maintenant le pionnier peu
plus que jamais avancé puisque on
n'échange que les fourniret alors ça
qu'on peut expliquer quand même si on
bouge le piment f sur la case f5 parce
qu'on aime pas sûr maintenant qu'on peut
le faire effectivement on ne peut pas à
cause de la fameuse prise en passant est
maintenant oui surtout à cause de
quelques 3 % c'est vrai il ya la
présentation mais du pion optèrent on
peut montrer d'abord peut-être très loin
la prise en passant possible ainsi des
marges ou f5
enfin pour le pire non mais le g5
prendrait un f6 et le pion f10 pas
disparaîtrait c'est la prise en passant
et sinon on va évidemment effectivement
une autre raison c'est que le footsie ce
serait cloué sur son roi à cause du fou
des syndicats oui d'ailleurs pour la
présentation je vous invite vraiment à
regarder l'émission des cours qui sera
disponible d'ici deux semaines où tout
toutes les règles du jeu d'échecs sont
expliqués deuxième émission hors
diagonale dit qu'on allait le sont tout
simplement dans la diagonale de son
nouvelle émission avec donc toutes les
règles du jeu d'échecs et comment
apprendre à arriver à être grand maître
international très vite
voilà hélas hélas au 22e coucou des
noirs tout ans et 5
on continue le combat pour la case des 5
l'idée maintenant est très simple fou
conquis le foufou cavaliers prend obligé
et dames aux sept ans b cet attaquant
une fois de plus la caisse des 5
et là les blancs ne pourrait plus de
tenir cette case voilà et après suivre
et des six des cinq avec un très gros
avantage noir au centre ils perdraient
surtout le cavalier au centre parce
qu'il ya la tour blanche derrière
au rayon du roug'chou menace assez
concrète qui oblige
garry kasparov à battre en retraite fou
4 et là ça y est le ressort se déplie
des six des cinq réussite totale pour
peter l'écho dans cette position
puisqu'il a deux fous le centre et tout
et tout et tout ce qu'on veut en fait
donc ici les blancs enfin les noirs ont
l'air mieux mais donc effectivement des
cinq ne va pas si bien que ça a marché
puisque il y avait des plans des 5
donc petite combinaison le pur été
reprises faut prendre des 5 fu prend des
50 et donc la capitale est qu à donner
un pion [ __ ] l'écho a sacrifié son
pion des six pour justement l'activité
qui arrive au 25e coup avec le cou aux 4
25-4 et là alors c'est là qu'on voit la
stratégie de peter l'écho alors là c'est
là où le parti devient belle puisque les
les blancs et c'est quand vous jouez une
stratégie de blocage pour absolument
bloquer léman on a vu qu'il a fallu se
battre énormément pour créer des menaces
à la fois éliminé ce sont de pures ou
quatre qui bloquait faire pression sur
la classe des cinq pour essayer de la
libérer et une fois que les blancs on
l'a libéré on donne un pion pour libérer
totalement ces pièces est donc là les
noirs se retrouve avec une pression très
dynamique et l'avantagent que les blancs
ont un problème avec le roi bien entendu
c'est le gros atout de la position noir
petit rock n'est toujours pas
d'actualité puisque l'euro sera le roi
serait tout simplement dans un réseau
épouvantable on peut envisager que la
d'un mythe passe par le 5 jusqu'au f4
attaquant de plus henri iv ainsi de
suite donc petit robot n'est pas
possible
et si on se demande vraiment comment
kasparov va réussir à mettre sa tour h
un enjeu puisque là les problèmes
concrets sont en train de commencer la
menace faite peut-être aux 83 pour
continuer la menace est également d'anne
sinclair monospace b4
les noirs sont partout ici quand j'ai vu
cette partie en direct je me suis dit ça
y est
kasparov il y est ça irait dans la boîte
il est dans la boîte il peut plus s'en
sortir il peut pas jouer tour h3 je vais
me voir à cause
17 à cause de thèmes des citoyens avec
attac nous à deux pièces à la fois ci la
tournée en jeu trois rings une
fourchette ou attaquer au choix d'amendé
sept qui est âcre et donc le fou des 5
et d'attachement donc cette tour peut
pas revenir en jeu par son monial et
kasparov la jouer au roi le 2 mai le
meilleur sinon ça c'est superbe
alors non mais faut quand même des cités
c'est que il faut il faut quand même moi
quand on voit ce coup là on demande le
pays nous devons nous fier à eux deux
c'est là que le roi et aux synthés les
pièces et demie sont en train de battre
et d'occuper le centre et la caf en
retrait sur un jour de semaine sur les
cases blanches parce que sur les cases
blanches il a des pièces qui peut
arriver
et puis prépare sur la poussée du pions
noirs le blocage par f3 donc il avance
son roi bloquer leurs pierres ont
apprises pendant dix années peut-être la
prise au sénat les plus assidus et donc
c'est un abri finalement invité
raisonnable plus que de faire petit
romain séparément de trouver un abri au
centre comme ça sous le feu ennemi
c'est paradoxal mais comme il a avancé
effectivement outre ses pions des deux
côtés oui là il faut plus rêver
le roi n'a plus de gaz ayant aussi aux
échecs souvent c'est un pion adverse qui
protège le mieux son propre droit
ça c'est une règle parce que quand il
parce qu'on peut pas se sacrifier sur un
tueur on peut pas ouvrir le une colonne
alors que ce sont nos chronos évidemment
donc une des idées pourraient être de
ramener cette tour en jeu puisque là
maintenant elle a le champ libre sur la
première rangée il suffit plus que
d'enlever la dame ça ça pour être l'idée
kasparov
voyons donc des recettes très logique de
peter l'écho en continu la
centralisation des pièces là d'amoureux
5 est parfaite on envisager de la mettre
en f4 puis en f3 donc là un échec picard
l'écho à une très très bien surtout en
attaque de fouet de la tacle fou vincent
la laque ou un petit peu surprenant dame
en c7
pourquoi pas oui lorsqu'il faut se
méfier des menaces de kehl
c'est dire si la dame donc on va revenir
27e ou si la dame venait en f4 suivre et
d'un des huit échecs avec et ceux comme
moi fouet fuite forcée mais fuite forcée
et maintenant et maintenant c'est
toujours assez chaud c'est compliqué
peut-être trop tard tout simplement on
peut ramener la tour en d1 parce qu'il
n'y a pas vraiment de menaces de noir et
lacazette va être très faible du côté
noir avec le fou qui l'attaqué la tour
pourra revenir sur la case 17 ou le dire
alors en h3c plus précis parce qu'à
contrôler non mais des fois il ya des
objets quatre échecs nom et surtout rage
croyais orange et 4 échecs et surtour
ailleurs les retours et 5 donc ici bon
encore une possibilité
beaucoup de possibilités mais
d'errements peter les colonnes lui il a
bien calculé tout ça et jouant d'un f4
on laisse les blancs avait des
possibilités d'attaqué me voir échec de
la g
mais quand le sacrifice du fou sur le
cas de cette taille aurait pas fabuleux
cause dame f6 y aurait fort ce qu'elle
change de damer finale finale peut-être
parce que windows phone 7 mais je prends
cette matrice et sa c29 6 cd même si
cela pointe peut-être un et six mois
après tout à fait alors newton ces sept
on se prémunit contre cet agent qui cite
les noirs sont mieux du crc les noirs
qui ont l'initiative en titre ont fait
savoir à la fois aux prévenus contre
l'échec de la dame mais aussi ont créé
une grande force sera collante et dont
les noirs oui ça m'a pas l'air d'être le
critère le plus important puisque
c'est assez moyen orient la suite alors
donc là voilà le 28e coup c'est un peu
le coup alors sa surprise nicolas
nicolas par amine et tu m'as dit dame g1
ou 28e coup soucoupe non mais on se
demande mais moi le roi redoux
légèrement j'ai trouvé ça bon alors dame
gisait maintenant non mais c'est cette
dame en sans l'aide de la protection du
roi mois alors comme ça de clôture
d'usagé cru à une erreur de transmission
j'étais vraiment rêver coquilles h et
bien j'ai vu sur internet donc j'ai
pensé à une erreur de trois éléments une
autre partie est il bon il faut que
j'attende qui remettra sans nom je les
regardais jusqu'à la fin mais en étant
un sceptique sur le ku'damm je me suis
bien et lui se tromper dans la
retransmission pas moi ça m'a surpris
aussi j'étais avec laurent frayssinet
quand on a regardé cette partie et mai
lors on a tout de suite compris en fait
non on a tout de suite compris l'idée je
me dis non mais bon t'as vu kasparov jo
dan g1
il est foutu c'est sûr et il m'a dit non
il m'a dit non ici kasparov passe à l'
attaque sur grenoble adam pas le
déranger un casse pas fatalement ça se
passe la menace et g5 un g6 on va ouvrir
cette colonne donc il faut attaquer sur
quatre manches puisque foot qu'on leur
pose est celle attaque qui prime alors
j'ai ici c'est le pion f5 ne peut pas
reprendre que tu acceptes et cloud et il
faut prendre du plomb h voilà la dame
temps angers 1 vient reprendre et se
retrouve sur un poste d'attaquant assez
assez
voilà parce que le pion à vii ne peut
pas prendre une amende à damas cause du
toujours du fou mais donc moi j'avais
beaucoup de mal à croire qu'un coup
comme g6 puisse être une menace sérieuse
puisque épreuve sur projet site d'un
projet 6 les blancs n'ont toujours pas
de menace directe
donc je me suis dit bon mais qu il a
deux coups pour jouer les testeurs off
qui est un roi sans rien rien autour
c'est pas possible qu'ils rien d
m 4 nages porte pas le nom il alterna il
a attaqué en jouant à quissac et indevus
bekaert ritter les courses sacrifier
encore bien ou pas de meuf 4 ça semble
très très fort donc d'un f4 n'y a pas de
réelle menace peut-être millions
d'objets droit tout simplement toujours
cet échange de données pourquoi pas
celle ci demande parce que les noirs
pour toujours et ce n'est pas ce qu'a
demandé longtemps ce projet si c'est
d'être au rachat emprise ouais y'a non
non il faut pas laisser la venue en f3
sont à 9,4 ou d'alger 3 chantage allait
changer d'âme on n'a pas une option de
plus il a donc ici peter l'écho continue
à attaquer donc chacun de son côté mais
avec le couvent l'a25 des quatre et il
veut créer si les blancs prennent en
fait donc là il sacrifie deuxième pion
peter lik au oui non et il met en
prennent en fait les noirs pourraient
envahir le camp adverse on pense
inévitablement à tour ces deux qui
sacrifie la qualité qui sacrifie la tour
contre un fou mais qui dans beaucoup
d'échecs possible avec il s'adonne au
minimum les chèques perpétuel et
peut-être mieux pour les noirs où elle a
peut-être casse groff n'a pas n'a pas
apprécié ça bien sûr n'apprécie pas
qu'on puisse faire nul quand on veut
contre lui donc il a préféré aller de
l'avant et aux voix prévient coup de
juger si ce don classe option
inacceptable on menace de prendre cette
menace de prendre un set avec le pion ce
qui créerait un pied monstrueux de la
voix il a menacé même plus violente que
ça c'est à dire c'est tout prend 1,7
je sais c'est laurent frayssinet qui me
l'a démontré on prend à vii aura fuite
il un clan fudan j'ai un transfuge et 7
avec échéances vont sacrifier la dame
on se croirait dans une étude oui ne me
proposait 7 le roi doit prendre est
maintenant donc là ça fait beaucoup de
flèches mais bon la droite challenge et
un taux inchangé avec échec et si le roi
vient ensuite pour l'empêcher de laine
blanc offert une deuxième date il ya
tour j'ai eu huit échecs et suivi d'un
suivi de damas c'est donc la menace
menaces violentes tout sur échec avec
matt encore une fois heureusement que
laurent frayssinet et là je prends g6
d'un projet 6
ici la menace maintenant ses tours j'ai
un tour je viens toujours tout rachat en
gêne et la cité sport enfin à jouer ça
une fois de plus il aura réussi à
retourner la situation
dire que là si on regarde toutes ces
paires seront la taxe alors qu'il ya
beaucoup on comprenait plus donc est ce
que les coûts ne peut pas jouer tour c4
et c4
il n'y a pensé je me rappelle plus ce
qu'on avait dit sur tours c4 je pense
que c'était simplement d'alger 5 qui
réitère la même menace
d'accord pour ses cartes effectivement
c'est une interception ouais
le curve 7 ne sera plus lourd il ya pas
il faut il faut qu'on avance là il faut
quand même sur la partie donc là le
picard le coach ou le courant et fuite
et là ils menacent maintenant de prendre
la dame puisque le pionner plus flou et
donc la menace et puis on prendra avec
gain oui donc une possibilité c'est de
jouer
demeurant car il ajoute mg3 d'un
prophète c'était impossible alors
évidemment voilà champion c'est
impossible que deux tours c'est 55
double dames et la dame serait perdu
donc évidemment d'alger 3 coffrets ce
parent oui c'est ça indom g3 est ici
peter l'écho arrête le combat puisque
peut-être qui peut-être qu'il était
fatigué il a un pur - c'est in
absolument il a vu une variante 2 nuls
forcé et donc il a joué cette variante
peut-être il était possible de continuer
le combat on confie j'ai cet art 5 pour
éviter les changes les dames
mais à mon avis c'est dire les co a vu
la vente nul il n'a joué il a échangé
les dames il était dans cette finale qui
ont plongé trois on voudrait que les
lampions maintenant dépenser trois
options qui étaient aux prises depuis
une belle lurette on l'avait tellement
oublier avec les menaces dannatt
ouais et finalement c'est qu'il y ait
bien comme ça et là la position il
récupère plutôt moins qualifiés 3 double
menace infondée 5 voilà attaque le four
b3 et l'option g3 mais bien entendu
garde à vue en foot et cinq attaques
l'option contre attaque surprise voilà
tout reprend g3 est là nul est conclue
puisque la position n'offrent plus
aucune chance d'apprécier des cinq
premiers aux quatre oui eh bien voilà il
se passe plus rien puisqu'on peut plus
gagner à ce niveau là et les joues
toujours ça peut très facilement faire
nul dans cette policière que même si on
enlève l'option hd blanc au plus on rêve
des noirs c'est encore un nul facile
voilà donc en tout cas très très jolie
partie est là on voit quand même que je
suis sur cette partie que j'ai que j'ai
le sentiment que peter l'écho il s'agit
il rentre dans la phase
oui il a gardé son sang froid et il a su
bien répondre à la violence de
l'ouverture ait aux préparations sans
doute de caspar entre et puis comment
kasparov s'est mis à trouver 7 me
dames excentré assez extraordinaire il
n'a pas perdu un rang plus son calme il
a joué b4 par exemple contre attaque
pour forcer kasparov la nuit il a été
vraiment impressionnant de sang froid
mais coup tout au long du tournoi les
donc ce que disait ses entraîneurs en
chinois c'est que il est un petit
prendre confiance mais qu il prend de
plus en plus de confiance il finit par
être très dangereux
oui c'est son manager qui disait ça donc
la parole la phrase est à prendre avec
des pincettes puisque son manager n'est
pas joueur d'échecs mais effectivement
c'est vrai qu'en l'écho et en conférant
aussi son entraîneur je crois aussi
amador un mano rodriguez qui lui est un
grand maître cubain oui il me dit non
mais c'est vrai que bon de toute façon
les coujoux très bien j'ai une petite
remarque encore source sûre ce package
de joueurs toujours un stand du syndicat
sparrow premier les trois autres joueurs
à nantes cramique et deco sont deuxièmes
ex-aequo et ces quatre joueurs n'ont pas
peur des deux parties se sont les seules
du championnat devait avoir lieu deux
parties ça démontre quand même solidité
énorme et ne serait-ce une progression
du jeu d'échecs en général quand on joue
pour la nulle je pense nicolas oui moi
j'ai été aussi étonné par d'une
nouveauté théorique la danse tourne à 2
g nique des cinquièmes coude une
défausse benfeld il joue un coup dans
une position très très connu tout simple
page 3 pas si vous avez vu ça
un grandes variantes forçant kasparov
finalement c'est de trouver la bonne
réponse alors que c'est une situation
ça prouve la richesse de jeu d'échec
qu'on a joué des millions de fois et
puis on n'a jamais pensé à ce petit coup
tout à fait ordinaire ça j'ai bien aimé
donc en fait l'échangé des idées dans ce
genre de tournoi avec l'élite des échecs
on assista comme ça des idées
foisonnantes
pour l'amateur on est vraiment enchantés
de pouvoir s'apercevoir des idées qu'ils
ont dans les ouvertures c'est avec
maintenant l'appui des ordinateurs les
coupes qu'il nous montre les nouveaux
coûts sont en général
contrôlé par ordinateur il n'y a pas de
olivier vérifier avec l'ordi s'entraîne
quand des ordinateurs que féliciter les
autorités d'intéressant pour tous les
amateurs c'est quand même dire qu'on
respecte arriver coûte que l'ordinateur
ne donne pas la vérité absolue et non
une indication une indication à la
correction du puis surtout il donne pas
l'idée derrière le cou ses idoles
l'horizon
les plus courts mais avec l intention
doit-on jouer ce coup il ne dit pas oui
tout à fait oui quel est le plan donc
par exemple dans cette partie les idées
les plans qui sont de vie c'est la case
des 5
le plus longtemps plus la machine non
par la machine en parlement il faut
retrouver devant l'échiquier on va là on
termine là sur ce prospectus du mois de
janvier donc cette actualité qu'on va
commenter la semaine prochaine le match
donc entre mais que la dame s'est
essayée rawan le numéro un américain aux
bermudes
le casse part au grand prix online et
puis peut-être de nouvelles soit grand
prix de bordeaux trophée c'est elle
c'est donc avec la participation de mme
adams lautier quatre chefs et laurent
frayssinet 6 et 7 avril prochain voilà
je vous dis donc à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle émission de diagonale
on
oh